[Music]
throughout history women have enhanced
their lips with color
cleopatra led the way over 2000 years
ago she used crushed ants and beetles to
redden her lips
today a tube of lipstick does the job
nicely no need to mess around with
crushed bugs
lipstick comes in a case that also
serves as an applicator and that's the
beauty of it
just twist the stick and apply color to
make lackluster lips look luscious
lipstick ingredients include waxes
pigments and moisturizers
a worker pre weighs everything following
a formula
the exact blends are usually a company
secret
she pours the measured ingredients into
a kettle that melts and mixes them
together
she adds a plant-based gel known as
plantalatum it will act as a skin
softener and also enable the lipstick to
be smoothly applied
different waxes carnauba candelila and
beeswax add body to the mixture
the waxes will also give the lipstick a
certain sheen upon application
with the base mixture prepared she now
whips up a batch of pigment using
different iron oxide colorants
she scoops it onto rollers that grind
the pigment particles while rolling it
into sheet form
[Music]
it takes three passes through the
rollers to fully grind the pigment
it's ready to be added to the base
mixture
she lowers the heat in the kettle to
avoid scalding the ingredients
she adds pigment until the mixture
thickens and becomes creamy
[Music]
it's now the right consistency to be
shaped into lipstick
[Music]
it's over to the next station where
another worker pours the lipstick liquid
into a filling machine
this filling system also has a mixer
that keeps the consistency creamy
she places a mold under the filling
machine and activates a lift
it serves up the mold to nozzles that
pump lipstick liquid into the slots of
the mold
she continues to fill lipstick molds
until the supply in the machine has been
depleted
she places the molds on a conveyor
which takes them through a nearly five
foot long cooling tunnel
the chili trip causes the lipstick
liquid to solidify
[Music]
the lipsticks are now ready for their
swiveling tubular containers
she places a rack on top of the mold and
inserts the cases into slots in the rack
the slots are aligned with the lipsticks
in the mold
then it's over to the turnaround machine
bursts of air gently push the lipstick
out of the mold and up into the cases
to assist little pushers apply pressure
to the bottoms of the cases
the lipsticks have made their transfer
without a smudge she sets them down and
removes the transfer rack
[Music]
on another conveyor the lipsticks pass
by heat guns
the hot air melts the lipsticks just a
little to make them shine
continuing on the lipsticks travel past
rollers that turn the cases to cause the
lipsticks to swivel down
a tester samples a lipstick from every
batch to determine the melting point
this is important because lipstick
should be stable enough not to melt in a
purse on a hot day
[Music]
he smears lipstick shavings onto a glass
disc and examines their consistency
[Music]
he places the sample on a heating
element and swings a magnifying glass
overhead for a close-up view as the
lipstick shapings melt into a puddle
checking the thermometer he confirms
that the melting point is within an
acceptable range
[Music]
another worker then compares the color
of the freshly made lipstick to the
standard and it's a match
[Music]
so they wrap a production with a plastic
cap
the cap is clear to showcase the shade
of the lipstick
[Music]
has taken about a day to manufacture
this lipstick
it's time to freshen up
you